es hagelt Kritik an den Beschlüssen der
Ampel darüber wollen wir reden mit
Robert habbeck Vizekanzler und Minister
für Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz guten
Abend nach Berlin hallo guten Abend sie
haben heute Mittag in Berlin den
bemerkenswerten Satz gesagt das tut mir
weh was an diesem Paket dass sie heute
beschlossen haben schmerzt sie am
meisten ach da will ich jetzt gar nicht
unterscheiden aber es ist natürlich
immer klar gewesen dass wenn wir nicht
Probleme die ja entstanden sind durch
die Situation in Europa also
Krieg der den Russland gegen die Ukraine
führt und durch die Wirtschafts und
energiepolitischen Krisen danach nicht
mehr durch Kredite heilen können wie das
jetzt ja verwerrt ist dass wir entweder
Gelder einsammeln müssen also mehr Geld
generieren müssen oder Programmtitel
streichen müssen und das haben wir jetzt
getan und das ist ja auch eine Zumutung
für bestimmte Teile der Bevölkerung oder
für bestimmte Wirtschaftssektoren das
ist nicht schön und ich verstehe den
Unmut aber es ist natürlich die einzig
denkbare Antwort und wir haben uns
entschieden möglichst breit einzelne
Maßnahmen zu machen deswegen hat es auch
so lange gedauert statt ganze Sektoren
oder ganze
Bevölkerungsgruppen in einem großen
Umfang zu betreffen tut's nicht aber
auch ein bisschen weh dass sie bei der
Förderung von Solarenergie kürzen
mussten aber nicht bei der reduzierten
Steuer auf Diesel denn die Kritik an
diesem Haushalt ist ja dass die
Maßnahmen nicht mutig genug sind dass es
kein Neustart ist sondern irgendwie ein
weiteres durchvorstellen reicht ihnen
das oder war einfach nicht mehr möglich
also so so nehme ich es nicht wahr die
Kritik die ich wahrnehme ist ein breiter
Chor an Kritik an jeweils einzelnen
Maßnahmen und gerade bei den wo
Verbräuche teurer werden also wir werden
ja jetzt eine Subventionierung der
chemischen Industrie die bisher vom
Staat getragen wird die sogenannte
plastikabgabe einführen sass also am
Ende die Verbraucher und die Verbraucher
für Plastikprodukte das sind werden nur
centbeträegge sein aber es werden eben
Centbeträge sein ein Beitrag zahlen
müssen das nehme ich wahr und wenn sie
nach dem Diesel Fragen also mit der
höheren CO2 Abgabe wir kehren ja auf den
Fahrt der großen Koalition zurück also
das was die Regierung Merkel beschlossen
hat wird jetzt wieder Realität wird auch
das Tanken teurer moderat sind
Centbeträge pro Liter aber auch das wird
teurer insofern glaube ich ist so wie
ich es war nä mir die Kritik nicht
ihr tut zu wenig sondern alle die
jeweils in bestimmten Bereichen Plastik
oder CO2 Abgabe betroffen sind sagen
hätte das denn nicht auch anders gehen
können genau also der CO2 Preis sie
haben es gesagt er steigt von jetzt 30 €
auf 45 € ab 1 Januar pro Tonne CO2
dadurch wird tanken und heizen teurer
außerdem streigt der steigt der
Strompreis und
m haben sie das durchgerechnet was das
für die Bürger heißt und über einen
Ausgleich nachgedacht das ist natürlich
sehr unterschiedlich wie viel gefahren
wird oder beruflich gefahren wird da
gibt es ja die Pendlerpauschale die wir
damals angehoben haben als die
Energiepreise für das Tanken so hoch
waren im Jahr 22 die ein Großteil dessen
noch abfedern werden aber es ist richtig
nicht mehr die alle Kosten die die Krise
ausgelöst hat können übernommen werden
bei den Netzentgelten ist es so dass
durch die hohen Energiepreise des
letzten Jahres die waren nicht mehr ganz
so hoch wie 22 aber immer noch höher als
im Normalfall wegen der höheren
Gaspreise die Netzentgelte so teuer
geworden sind wir wollten die übernehmen
wir hatten dafür einen Fond wir hatten
das schon als Gesetz fertig gemacht und
im Grunde schon beschlossen aber dann
wurde dieser Fond nach dem Urteil von
Karlsruhe aufgelöst und wir haben keine
weiteren
Refinanzierungsmöglichkeiten gefunden
die auch noch zu übernehmen es wäre noch
mal 5üninhalb Milliarden gewesen dafür
gab es dann keine Möglichkeit mit die
uns eingefallen wäre ohne weitere
Belastung an anderen Stellen wo wir sie
nicht haben wollten auszulösen genau und
das müssen jetzt die Verbraucher zahlen
wie glauben sie wird das bei den Wählern
ankommen die ja im Moment sowieso nicht
riesen Fans der Ampelkoalition
sind wenn man keine Schulden mehr
aufnehmen darf und man sich politisch
vereinbart hat keine Steuern zu erhöhen
dann gibt es ja eigentlich nur noch zwei
denklogische Konsequenzen entweder der
Staat übernimmt weniger Leistung also
federt nicht mehr alle Kosten ab die ja
aus dem System heraus entstehen sind ja
keine Kosten die durch den Krieg den wir
uns ausgedacht haben SN sie kommen von
außen die hohen Energiepreise kamen von
außen und dann haben wir sie versucht
abzufedern mit Schulden mit Krediten das
geht jetzt nicht mehr nach dem Urteil
oder wir müssen mehr Einnahmen machen
wir haben jetzt beides getan wir haben
Subventionen gestrichen also mehr
Einnahmen für den Staat organisiert aber
wir können auch nicht mehr alle Lasten
übernehmen das ist die die Konsequenz in
der politischen Realität in der wir sind
natürlich verstehe ich dass das Leute
darüber nicht fröhlich sind wer will
schon gerne mehr Geld bezahlen aber es
war immer klar also mir war das vom Tag
ein an klar nach dem Urteil was das
bedeutet und das darf ich noch mal sagen
dass es nicht verwechselt wird das hat
an dieser Stelle nichts mit dem Klima
und transformationsfond zu tun also der
Unterstützung der Wirtschaft da haben
wir unsere Probleme selbst gelöst ja es
ist sogar so und das kann ich noch
dazufügen dass wir in dem Klima und
transformationsfond die EEG Umlage
beibehalten also wie die übernehmen wir
die als Staat wir sorgen also dafür dass
Verbraucher und Verbraucher beim
Strompreis auch entlastet werden das hat
man daran hat man sich jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon gewöhnt aber
trotzdem ist es nicht nur allesbastung
sondern wir verteidigen auch die
Entlastung okay kommen wir noch mal
zurück zur Schuldenbremse das ist ja so
ein bisschen etikettenschwendel denn sie
lassen sich ja zwei Hintertürchen offen
einmal bei der Hilfe für die Flutopfer
und einmal bei der Hilfe für die Ukraine
warum sagen Sie nicht einfach Leute wir
schaffen es nicht ohne
Schulden ich sehe es anders es ist kein
Etikettenschwindel sondern ganz im
Gegenteil wir übernehmen ja jetzt durch
die jetzt eben andiskutierten Maßnahmen
Kosten die durch den ukrainekrieg
ausgelöst sind wir unterstützen die
Ukraine mit 8 Milliarden Militärhilfe
also kaufen Waffen für Sie wir haben
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine in
Deutschland was ungefähr kosten von 6
Milliarden verursacht und dann gibt es
noch Aufbau Position all das finanzieren
wir nicht über Kredite und Schulden weil
man jetzt auch ein Zeichen setzen wollte
dass wir diesen einfachen bequemen Weg
nach dem Urteil nicht erneut gehen
sondern finanzieren es aus dem Haushalt
es ist also gerade nicht der billige Weg
die Schuldenbremse zu
überspielen das einzige was der
Bundeskanzler gesagt hat und ich sage
das gleiche ist wenn die Ukraine weitere
Hilfe braucht weil es an der Front
schwierig wird weil das Land sich mehr
verteidigen muss weil Russland mehr
drohen schickt wenn wir also noch mehr
tun müssen dann wird es nicht gelingen
über noch höhere Bepreisung von
bestimmten Verbräuchen diese
diese Ausgaben zu stemmen und das finde
ich auch korrekt und richtig und das ist
mein Ansicht nach auch völlig in Rahmen
mit dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts wenn eine noch
größere not entsteht dann wird man auch
darüber nachdenken müssen die Notlage
wieder auszurufen allerletzte Frage nach
diesem haushaltsmarathon und
durchverhandelten Nächten was hält die
Ampel noch zusammen außer demem Willen
zur Macht nein aber das ist doch ein
Beweis wie handlungsfähig wir sind wir
sind alle über unseren Schatten
gesprungen niemand hat dir sein
lieblings oder Parteiprogrammen
durchgesetzt hat lange gedauert das
liegt daran dass wir uns viel intensive
Debatte gegönnt haben um die richtigen
Entscheidungen zu treffen aber es zeigt
doch dass wir in der Lage sind
schwierige ich meine was gibt's denn für
Politiker unpopulärere Sachen als
Belastung für die Bevölkerung zu
beschließen und das tragen wir gemeinsam
keiner stielt sich aus der Verantwortung
und deswegen ist das eher Tag der noch
mal zeigt was diese Regierung leisten
kann sagt Robert habbeck Vizekanzler und
Wirtschaftsminister vielen Dank für das
Gespräch und einen guten Abend nach
Berlin danke
[Musik]
schön